Netflix's Cowboy Bebop is like a live-action
jam session, riffing on the much-loved original
anime about a bunch of bounty hunters in space.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan, and
in this video I'm explaining the jazziest
differences between the new show and the animated
classic.
At 49 years of age, John Cho may be over 20
years older than his character Spike Spiegel
was in the original anime, but what the actor
lacks in youth he more than makes up for with
acres of effortless cool.
As the show's lead space cowboy Cho exudes
laid-back charisma and wry wit, breathing
entertaining life into Spike's often cynical
and cavalier approach to the world, while
also managing to tap into his darkness and
vulnerability.
Interestingly, portraying vulnerability was
something Spike's English-language voice actor
in the anime, Steve Blum, said he found especially
difficult.
And that's a benefit John Cho sees of coming
to the role as a more mature actor as he says
he's better now at "showing weakness and vulnerability
and love" so is more able to do "justice to
the emotional depth [they've] tried to give
Spike".
As for creating Spike's look, Cho trained
hard to become what he calls "functionally"
rather than "show-horse athletic" to get a
good performance and also developed a "character
walk" for the first time in his career, by
"watching how Spike moves in the original
series".
And that hair is Cho's own grown out, rather
than a wig, which he was keen to avoid so
it would feel and look more natural and wouldn't
pull on his scalp during the show's many action
scenes.
Equally superb is Mustafa Shakir as former
cop Jet Black.
Fans of Marvel's Luke Cage will doubtless
remember the actor as Bushmaster in season
2 of that show.
In Cowboy Bepop, Shakir brings his anime counterpart
to pitch-perfect life with a seen-it-all-before
gruffness mixed with heart and humour, as
well as great on-screen chemistry with Cho.
This time around, a young daughter's included
in Jet's backstory, adding a personal layer
to the professional hurt he suffered in his
past.
While that's not really necessary to get us
on board with his character, it does lead
to a small but emotionally devastating moment
for him as well as some amusing moments along
the way, my favourite of which is him watching
his daughter's school performance in the foreground
totally oblivious to Spike fighting a slew
of baddies alone in the background.
The third member of the Bebop's crew, Faye
Valentine, arrives on the scene a bit earlier
than in the anime;
and given Daniella Pineda's fantastic turn
as Faye, that's absolutely for the best.
Pineda's take on the bold, brash amnesiac
brings a sense of wicked fun to the show whenever
she's on screen, whether she's bantering with
Spike and Jet or getting herself or others
into and out of crazy jams, like in the ridiculously
good seventh episode.
With the odd exception, Faye doesn't keep
abandoning the team as her animated counterpart
often did, which improves the chemistry she
has with her fellow bounty hunters.
In fact, all three lead actors work together
brilliantly, producing a truly entertaining
dynamic.
Plus, Pineda imbues Faye's search for her
missing past with a quiet melancholy and it'll
be interesting to see how her hunt for answers
pans out in season 2.
As for her appearance, obviously she was going
to look different in the real world and her
updated outfit reflects that while nodding
to the original.
If you've watched Amazon's superhero series
The Boys, you'll likely recognise actor Alex
Hassell who played Translucent in that show
and stars as Vicious in Cowboy Bebop.
How much you enjoy his turn here depends on
how theatrical you like your villains.
Compared to the anime, we see much more of
Vicious in the live-action series.
Given he's the show's main antagonist, building
up his character and expanding his backstory
makes sense as it makes him feel much more
obviously integral to the story from the get-go.
But the penultimate episode that lays out
his journey to becoming a Syndicate capo and
his relationship with Spike is one of the
less interesting ones as it feels we've either
been told or intuited enough already, so it
ends up seeming like an overlong interruption
before the big finale.
Oh, and if you're wondering what happened
to Vicious's pet cormorant from the anime,
the new show's creative team made an early
decision to give it the chop, which is understandable
given the added VFX costs to create something
that's not exactly crucial.
However, they did include various easter eggs
to the bird on Vicious's costume.
Julia, who is Vicious's wife and Spike's former
flame, also gets a lot more screen time than
she did in the original series where she was
more enigmatic.
But she still mainly exists just to be part
of a love triangle, and actress Elena Satine
does what she can with a character who's mostly
there to appear fragile and sultry.
Fortunately, there's a hint of more interesting
times ahead given where the show leaves her
character, and I'm intrigued to see where
the creators take things in Season 2.
By the way, Satine gets to showcase her singing,
and according to John Cho, also plays the
piano herself in the series, performing a
new song that's important for Julia.
Similar to the anime, Welsh corgi and "data
dog" Ein turns up in the lives of the Bebop
crew thanks to a run-in with a pet napper
named Hakim.
In the live-action series, two super-cute
canines, Harry and Charlie, bring Ein to absolutely
adorable life, though according to the show's
two male leads they were pretty heavy to carry
around!
As well as the real-life pups, John Cho says
he also spent a lot of time acting opposite
a stuffed toy dog to get his eye alignment
right in scenes where Ein was off-screen.
In terms of how the show's adapted overall,
it gets off to a delightfully playful, wacky
start with Spike and Jet at a casino on the
hunt for their latest criminal cash-cow.
The scene is a joy to watch, from Spike's
elevator entrance and fancy fighting footwork
including a casino chip drop-kick, to Jet's
arrival crashlanding through the ceiling,
to the duo's bickering, best-mates back-and-forth.
Rather than simply remaking the original episodes
or creating an entirely different narrative
with the same core characters, the live-action
series aims to retain the anime's spirit and
takes a pick 'n' mix approach to its plots
and characters.
In other words, they "get everybody and the
stuff together", but in a variety of ways.
For instance, the first episode takes a similar
tack to the anime pilot, introducing Asimov
and Katerina and their attempted Red Eye drug
deal;
but in a change, it also introduces Faye.
How the creative team rejigs or remixes elements
often works, but at times they don't quite
pull it off.
For example, I was glad I already knew the
anime when I watched the ecoterroism episode
with Maria Murdock because the live-action
take on that felt a bit too rushed to fully
take in properly.
Each episode gives the Bebop crew fresh criminals
to bounty hunt, like in the anime.
However, this version takes more regular time
from the start to expand on the crew's histories,
so those episodes feel less like standalone
stories and more clearly like part of a bigger,
overarching narrative.
The series is packed with easter eggs and
hat-tips to the original, from building names
to complete shots.
And composer Yoko Kanno is back with new music
as well as old favourites, including her iconic
opening theme tune, thank goodness because
I really love that!
So, spoilers now for the Season 1 ending.
The appearance of hacking whiz kid Radical
Edward was teased a few times this season.
I've got a lead from Radical Ed.
But Ed only appears right at the very end.
Even though it's just a brief glimpse, we
can see this version has the signature look
and the hyper, childlike energy and smiley
eccentricity you'd expect.
However, fan reactions have been mixed.
with some suggesting that Ed's anime oddness
doesn't translate well to live action.
We'll have to wait for Season 2 to see exactly
how the character plays out, but I wonder
whether Radical Ed will hack into the Bebop
to force Jet to come and join her, Spike and
Ein, similar to how she hijacked the ship
in the anime.
Although anime Ed's entertaining on screen,
in a world of ever increasing data hacks and
breaches, getting yourself a trustworthy virtual
private network is a crucial part of keeping
your online life private and secure, which
is why at Flicks And The City we recommend
NordVPN who've sponsored this video.
Whether you're using public Wi-Fi or at home,
you're at risk from hackers who can break
into your connection and access any personal
data being transmitted.
A VPN protects your privacy by encrypting
your internet connection and preventing your
internet service provider, the government,
or snoopers from knowing what websites you're
visiting and from reading your private messages.
And it's also a powerful tool that can help
you bypass geo-location blocks so that you
can access content not available to view or
censored in your country.
Something we especially like about Nord is
the super-fast download speeds on its 5,000-PLUS
servers and how it uses next-gen VPN technologies
like Wireguard.
And with our exclusive cyber month offer,
you can get a huge 73% off a two-year plan
plus one month free.
Just visit NordVPN.com/Flicks or tap the link
in the video description to access the offer.
Or use coupon code FLICKS when you check out.
Now, what did you think of the new Cowboy
Bebop?
And who's your favourite character in either
version?
Let me know in the comments below, and if
you enjoyed this, then a thumbs-up and share
are hugely appreciated.
Next tap here to learn about the biggest changes
between Dune 2021 and Dune 1984 or tap right
for something else you're sure to like.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!